given how quickly ai is advancing given
how quickly disruptive technologies
advance and given how much damage it's
doing to our civil society what the the
the behavioral impact that it has on our
kids there's no question this is urgent
and and i will say that unlike all the
other crises that i have in the book
this is the one that if you ask me ian
is this a goldilocks crisis can we get
this right
i know we can get the other ones right
i'm not sure on this one
[Music]
[Music]
back on forward author of the brand new
book the power of crisis how three
threats and our response will change the
world founder of eurasia group at g zero
you know him as bill maher's best friend
ian bremmer is back ian welcome hey you
know him as a good buddy of andy yang
too so you know i'm not i'm perfectly
happy with that
me too
so grateful so uh ian you're like the
oracle i turn to when i want to figure
out what the heck is going on in the
world and you've been incredibly in
demand lately because so much has been
going on in the world but you started
writing this book
um i'd imagine sometime during the
pandemic and
uh events are now dramatically unfolding
around the world you had a piece in your
book about
russia's invasion of ukraine like what's
your latest perspective on that i there
was part of me when the conflict broke
out i thought to myself wow if ukraine
can hold on long enough
that russia would would lose or give up
but here we are like a number of weeks
later
what's the latest on that front well let
me first say that you're right i started
writing the power of crisis uh during
the pandemic
and the idea was that we are in a
target-rich environment right now in
terms of global crisis there are all
sorts of people that are writing books
that are telling you the sky is falling
and the wheels are going to fall off
and and you and i have never been
comfortable with that kind of analysis
we want solutions and i thought that was
really not only space for but really
necessity for
one book out there that said how is it
that we can and are
taking advantage of some of these crises
to deal with some of the challenges that
have made us increasingly very anxious
and despondent over the last decades and
and indeed we are and starting with
russia ukraine which wasn't
an active crisis when i started writing
the book but certainly was by the time i
finished it it's absolutely true i mean
think about just in the last day
finland
is now going to join nato and in very
short order sweden's going to make that
announcement too
that wasn't remotely possible before the
russian invasion of ukraine indeed nato
was adrift president macron said it was
brain dead and now nato not only has a
mission but it's more consolidated the
germans are spending the money on
defense that four successive u.s
presidents have begged them to do and
they refused the asian allies are all
coming to the munich summit in june
they're much more aligned as well so
it's not a pivot to asia instead of
europe it's the world's advanced
democracies working together in response
to this horrible decision by the russian
president to invade a country a
neighboring country of some 44 million
people whose only sin
is to want to
elect their own leadership so yeah we
can get into how it's going but i mean
the first thing we should say and how
it's going is that actually the west
looks more coherent it has more
leadership democracy seems to matter
more and indeed three months in
there are six million ukrainian refugees
in europe
but
the key of government is still standing
and and zielenski is still president and
almost no one would have presumed that
certainly not putin
and and he the reason he invaded is
precisely because he believed that the
west wouldn't be interested in and
willing to respond to p i think if he
had an inclination
that this crisis would mobilize the west
to actually respond effectively he
wouldn't have invaded in the first place
so good thing that putin didn't read my
draft
i mean it seems like he badly badly
miscalculated i was in dc last month and
i met with a couple of senators who just
come back
from uh ukraine and visiting the front
they were actually in poland i'm not
sure if they went through to ukraine but
they were meeting with uh the polls in
particular to see how they could be that
trip didn't go to ukraine that trip went
to they went to poland i think they went
to uh they were in georgia
uh they were in france and they were one
of them they might be in italy too yeah
yeah so so you know it well oh yeah
and i also saw a story about this polish
high school that was
uh welcoming in that case it was maybe
like dozens of ukrainian students it was
in a way very wholesome it humanized the
whole thing because you realize that uh
these ukrainians who fled i mean they're
still teenagers and they still need to
go to school and so the polish school is
like hey i guess you're joining this
school and so that like they if you can
imagine your high school all of a sudden
having a hundred new uh new students and
they were all sitting together learning
uh and some of the ukrainian teenagers
were describing how it felt like the
safest they'd been in you know uh days
or weeks and like a dose of normalcy
since i got from the senators also was
like that they weren't sure how long
this conflict was going to go on for
is time uh on the ukrainian side or or
is it
uh but can can one tell
i wouldn't say that time is on the
ukrainians side there are a couple
things that we know
we know
that russia has become a pariah for the
g7 um you know that that the
relationship between russia and the us
and europe has been broken and that's
permanent
um we're not going to unfreeze their
assets
we're not going to start buying energy
from them again once that gets cut off
that's it and that's a g20 economy
that's unprecedented since the soviet
union has collapsed it's a really big
deal
we also know that europe is much more
cohesive that the eu matters a lot more
it mattered more coming out of the
pandemic because they responded in a
unified way in a way that the united
states frankly did not uh but also in
response to what they see as an
existential threat um from russia to all
of europe not just to ukraine it's very
real it's very immediate for them and
that's one of the reasons macron ended
up winning much more easily in the
second round once he started to start a
campaign uh which was late uh because
people recognized like we can't have a
euro-skeptic president when we're facing
this kind of a threat from russia it's
just we need the eu and that that's a
good thing even poland which was much
more euroskeptic now you mentioned
poland they're accepting millions of
ukrainian refugees in their home they're
taking a lead in europe and wanting more
leadership more leadership on security
and defense more leadership on economic
integration those are all positive
things for democracy around the world
you want that kind of an example but
but let's be clear i mean we already
know
of thousands of ukrainians that have had
war crimes committed against them
tortures rapes
we've seen what's happened in bucha
we've seen what's happened on the ground
in merida poll and there's going to be
so much more of this i mean this is
going to be the defining issue
for generations
of ukrainians whose lives are being
completely uprooted and the fact is that
russia's
spends
ten times as much on defense
as ukraine does
so um it's true
that um the west has done a fantastic
job and the ukrainians have done a
fantastic job very courageous in
fighting and ensuring that they can keep
most of their country
but this is an act of war and there's
nothing from putin's speech on victory
day so-called victory day may 9th which
in principle celebrates when the soviets
defeated the nazis but this year of
course putin made it everything but that
um there was nothing from that speech
that would lead anyone to believe that
he's going to back down that he's going
to withdraw his troops that he's
thinking about suing for peace in fact
they're presently moving towards
formally annexing much of the territory
that they've already managed to occupy
so i think as we look forward another
three six twelve months
the best possible scenario for ukraine
is that they manage to fight the
russians to pretty much a draw
and we get a frozen conflict and then
the west and maybe others maybe even the
chinese who have privately
said to many people that they'd be
interested in potentially sending
peacekeepers if we could get a ceasefire
there is a possibility that you could
get a frozen conflict that leaves the
west much stronger and much more
cohesive and and kind of and and
constrains this unexp unacceptable
unspeakable damage that's been done to
the ukrainian people
[Music]
who couldn't use someone to talk to
nowadays it's one reason why i'm so glad
that this podcast is sponsored by better
help online therapy what is better help
it is an on-demand professional trained
therapist who can come to you in the
privacy of your own home and give you
the help that you need better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to i know some of us just prefer to chat
to text to type
it's like that but there's a human on
the other end who will give you the not
just listening with the feedback the
guidance the therapy
that a lot of us could use frankly it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours this podcast
is sponsored by better help and forward
listeners get 10 off their first month
at
betterhelp.com yang that's b e t t e r h
e l p
dot com slash yang
[Music]
well you mentioned china
and a number of people have said to me
that one potential silver lining of this
is that
other countries are seeing what's
happening with russia becoming a pariah
on the economic harm and and the fact
that there have been really negative
ramifications for the regime as
something that might discourage other
countries from undertaking uh shall we
say something that that involves some
form of aggression against a neighbor
is that a potential silver lining out of
this well i mean i i know how personal
the taiwan issue is for you that is what
i was thinking yeah i mean yeah
and and and you and i have spoken about
this in the past i was not someone who
believed that china was interested in
suddenly invading taiwan imminently
but certainly that is an enormous point
of not just friction but direct
confrontation between the united states
and china between the western china we
have said that we will defend the
taiwanese and you know biden says it and
then you know the u.s back you know
walks it back a bit because you know in
principle we're not supposed to make
that formal statement but but instead
help the taiwanese defend themselves but
i i think the chinese have seen very
clearly two things
first they've seen that in response to
ukraine which is much less strategically
important to the us than taiwan is
um in terms of the nature of its economy
uh the advanced nature of its democracy
the critical importance of its
semiconductor production
they see look at what they did in
ukraine
clearly the level of commitment to
taiwan is likely to be greater than we
we saw before
and and when putin met with xi jinping
in february 4th 20 days before the
invasion back in the beijing olympics
and he basically said you know they
announced this great friendship without
limits and he said look i'm going to
attack ukraine uh and and it wasn't
talked about as a war was talked about
as a special military operation because
putin was convinced that the ukrainians
weren't going to fight that the russians
were just going to go in and take kiev
and zelensky would be out of you a few
days maybe two weeks max well the
chinese are seeing that that is not what
has happened and that the russians are
performing very badly on the ground and
and this is a military that hasn't
fought for decades and that's part of
why the russians aren't capable aren't
ready and and the chinese absolutely
take a lesson for that because the
chinese military hasn't fought for
decades and so they're looking around
and going
we may not have the capacity
to respond to the americans if if taiwan
gets chippy or the east or the south
china sea gets chippy in a way that we
think we do we we better go back
and sharpen our pencils on this
so i i think it buys time i think it
creates some realism on the part of
beijing and and i think it creates
greater understanding that american
military power and allied military power
including the quad including occus and
bolstered by the indo-pak economic
framework which is being developed none
of those should be taken lightly by a
government in china that frankly has
more than its own share of problems this
year yeah when you talk about those
problems uh you know there have been
images uh and videos circulating about
some of the uh the lockdown efforts uh
in shanghai in particular where i do
have family
and one of the things that i've heard
from a number multiple people is that
there's a lot of
anger and resentment uh in china among
the chinese
where uh their leadership is concerned
uh you know that there's also a rise in
nationalism is what i hear it's like
there's a lot you know there there was
uh as of last year like uh frankly like
a greater degree of uh animus towards
like uh the us um but but it but any
from what i'm hearing and this is just
from like you know half a dozen people
anecdotal yeah yeah yeah i know
personally that that they're suggesting
that there's a lot of anger and
discontent uh towards the regime
so i mean in the same way that in russia
the overwhelming response is anger at
the west and as the economy gets worse
they're going to blame the west for
those sanctions they're not principally
going to blame their own russian
government if the war is not going well
they're going to say nato is fighting us
this is the reason in china i agree
there is a lot of nationalism there is a
lot of feeling like this is about the
west that you know the the chinese
locked down
their population and prevented coven
from spreading and the west didn't care
the west particularly didn't care about
their old people don't respect their old
people and allowed a million americans
to die because they weren't prepared to
wear masks they weren't prepared to be
responsible they just didn't care and
and they see that as a failure of
western governance so i would not
underestimate the importance of
nationalism especially because that
message is bolstered on social media by
state linked actors and bolstered on
state media every day every morning
every night but if you are in shanghai
and of course you know the average
shanghainese
is wealthier than the average citizen of
of portugal i mean this is the
wealthiest uh city in china they've done
extravagantly well over the past 40
years it's a world-class city there's a
level of arrogance uh among chinese that
live there that you know everything
works well here we aren't like a
second-tier city we're not like a rural
area and then suddenly a four-day
lockdown becomes a one month lockdown
and they're having
and it's managed badly where children
that are positive tested positive or
stripped away from their parents where
pets are taken away and culled
um where you know they're having a hard
time getting food they can't leave their
complex they're not getting good
information i mean this is absolutely
angering them primarily with local
government
but increasingly that level of
frustration
is broader um and and some of that is
coming out even to the west despite the
chinese government's best efforts to uh
to clamp it down um and i i look i think
that the chinese government did do a
fantastic job
in ensuring once they admitted that
covet existed which of course was
several weeks after it actually existed
they were able to get to track to trace
to lock down and get their economy
running again by the second quarter of
2020 it's been interesting there were
different periods because i have family
over there yeah and so there were
periods when we were on lockdown when
they were you know finally open again
and then yeah and then things that were
kind of flipped i mean they were going
to nightclubs and they were proud of
that they were very proud of that but
what really hurts me
and this is i mean looking at my book
looking at the power of crisis i mean
this was a failure
is that this pandemic
did not in any way
bring together blue states and red
states in the u.s or the us and china
and what we're seeing right now is that
the chinese
in their arrogance of the government
are so unwilling
to support
um the us and europe in sending them
mrna vaccines that work
we have the single greatest commodity in
global surplus in the world right now
when you have inflation and challenges
on supply chain everywhere the one
commodity that is in greatest global
surplus are mrna coveted vaccines we
have produced the living hell out of
those things we have them we can give
them to you in africa the problem is not
that we don't have vaccines is that they
don't have the infrastructure to deliver
them to the people and so they'll expire
before they can get into arms china has
that infrastructure they can get those
vaccines to the people but they refuse
to license western vaccines
because they can't admit
that we got that done faster and better
than they did who cares like we're one
humanity it's one virus that morphs over
time we have to work together and the
chinese absolutely refuse and you know
what the horrible thing is the reason
they're refusing is because this crisis
isn't big enough
they think they can deal with it they
see the light at the end of the tunnel
they're going to get their own mrna
vaccines by the end of the year they can
handle the lockdown xi jinping gets his
third term they can pump enough money
into the economy to make it work they're
too stable they're too rich to actually
and the crisis was too small kovat
didn't hit them bad enough
to to require
us to get beyond ourselves and work
together as one name as one people yeah
that is the theme of your book which i
enjoyed a great deal and it opens with a
story that i did not know um which is of
reagan and gorbachev getting together
and then reagan asks him a question is
like hey if aliens invaded and we were
fighting them would you help us and then
gorbachev was like sure i would
then gorgeous shares the story later and
then it's later decades later and then
some people take it somehow as like uh
you know like a a negative on reagan and
i was like you kidding it's a great
question it's a great sentiment and
uh you know i'm really glad that that
was like a bonnie experience for them
and i felt like a lot of your book was
around like okay what are the aliens of
today
that's exactly you know that turned out
that reagan was apocryphal he was
decades ahead of his time
because if you talk today about covid
or you talk today
about uh climate change or you talk
about the potential of world war three
with the russians rattling their nuclear
sabers against the west
these are the conversations that we have
to be having okay well none of us want
this to happen and so no we don't trust
each other democrats and republicans we
don't like each other we're really
dysfunctional right now americans and
chinese we don't trust each other we're
trying to contain each other but i mean
if you're facing this kind of an
imminent existential crisis
wouldn't you
just like gorbachev be willing to set
aside your differences to fight the
aliens and the answer has to be yes
the answer has to be yes and the fact
that the answer hasn't even been yes in
the united states between democrats and
republicans which is why you started
your new party right i mean you're one
of the very few americans that not only
a lot of people are angry about this but
how many people are willing to try to do
something to respond to it why why did
we get andrew yang
you know i mean you could have done lots
of others i asked myself that same
question every day
well i mean we got you because the
american political system was
increasingly broken and dysfunctional
for decades and you said okay i'm gonna
do something about that
want to talk to you guys about a new
sponsor we have called air table and if
you've ever tried to do any sort of
leadership activity or startup you have
seen airtable at least be offered to you
as an awesome solution in this ever
changing landscape of work how can you
ensure your people workflows and data
stay connected airtable is how airtable
allows you to create flexible systems
that help your team operate as one i've
used it a few times different orgs and
it's fantastic so break down the
barriers that leave teams feeling
disconnected with airtable your team
works from a single source of truth that
is always up to date and keeps everyone
on the same page so with their adaptable
approach everyone from marketers to
product teams to podcast producers can
build tools that fit uniquely to the way
they work plus airtable keeps individual
projects connected to your higher level
goals so you never lose sight of what
you're working toward it's pretty
awesome so give it a try for free at
airtable.com today that's airtable.com
to get started for free check it out
guys a massively helpful tool
[Music]
so that that's one of the
scenarios you you or the concerns you
lay out in your book
around the fact that one you have this
u.s china rivalry and two you have this
uh polarization in the u.s that may keep
us from being able to come together and
get things done and you pose as
potential
unifying threats i think one that
everyone can understand very readily
which is climate change uh and one of
the things i love about you
and the book is that you are ultimately
very constructive
and positive saying look like if you
wanted to you could
have green marshall plan that applies
not just in one part of the world but
actually creates the right incentives
for both developed and developing
countries to start meaningfully
addressing climate change well the the
indian government did not india did not
have a spring this year
um they have wet bulb temperatures um
that are unsustainable and unlivable for
over a billion people
of their 1.4 billion outside which means
that the combination of heat and
humidity is so great that the body
cannot cool itself
so you can't
you've got laborers that are not allowed
to work after 10 a.m because literally
they wouldn't be able to survive in
those conditions a billion of of of
india's 1.4 billion and and that's
because of climate change it's
unprecedented it's the hottest march in
april on record in india it's only going
to get worse and the indian government's
response is we cannot and will not turn
away from the coal that we need to
ensure that we have energy to ensure
that we can cool our buildings unless
you guys the rich countries that put all
the carbon in the atmosphere and got us
here are willing to do something about
it um and and who blames them
who would possibly blame them now the
constructive piece of this
is that after largely ignoring this
issue for decades we aren't ignoring it
anymore the constructive piece of this
is that the world's banks that have a
longer-term perspective because they
have portfolios that are you know
10-year horizon
understand that they can't get a return
from thermal coal and so they're
overwhelmingly investing in renewables
and in new generation nuclear so much so
that the cost at scale of these new
technologies to deliver energy
are starting to become much cheaper than
fossil fuels so as i look forward andrew
2045 latest i think the world a majority
of the world's energy will no longer
come from oil and gas and coal five
years ago no one would have said that
and that is a direct response to crisis
and it's despite the fact that the
americans are divided and dysfunctional
it's despite the fact that the chinese
don't trust the americans and vice versa
because everyone on the planet sees this
as a problem so young people came out
and they said we're not going to buy
from you as companies unless you take
this seriously and the banks did it and
the europeans did it the japanese did it
and when trump pulled out of the paris
climate accord the mayors and the
governors said no we're sticking with it
and they did so i i actually i think of
i call this a goldilocks crisis
it's not so big that you're despondent
because you know you have no shot and so
you just curl up in a ball and it's not
so small that you couldn't be bothered
and climate change actually is a
goldilocks crisis it's exactly the size
that shows humanity that if we get our
act together in focus we can save the
planet and we are actually on track to
do that now if you listen to antonio
gutierrez the secretary general of the
u.n who is not just a good friend but
his quotes on the back of the book so
you would kind of wonder well wait a
second when he talks publicly he's not
as optimistic as ian is what's going on
here well no of course not because you
can't have the world leaders act as if
mission is accomplished because then
we'll stop
like we there's a huge amount to play
for between
1.5 degrees of warming and 2.5 degrees
of warming that will affect the lives of
hundreds of millions of people and
countless species that are facing
extinction on the planet so we need
those leaders to keep leaning in and to
panic people a little bit more but but
the reality is for you and me trying to
understand what's happening on the
planet is we are starting to get this
right right and that's a i think that's
a that's an incredibly inspiring and
hopeful message it is interesting you
characterize that because it's true we
all have roles to play and if a
government leader or someone like
antonio was like hey we're in great
shape then the urgency diminishes look
how much we've done
take a year off guys
we can't do that but that's one reason
why i can't be secretary general it's
really for the best
so the next solution you propose which
is something that i'm a thousand percent
for uh we're talking about it back
during my presidential campaign i know i
know is the world data organization
uh and so people know that uh i'm
passionate about the fact that our data
is getting sold and resold and it's not
just here in the us
in the us if you had to put a number on
it it's over 200 billion dollars
a year in revenue from our data
good times if you look at the
market caps of facebook slash meta as an
example i mean most all of that is on
the backs of our data and their uh
market cap is you know over a trillion
last i checked so
this is
an outgrowth of advancing technology and
developing ai uh that you see as
potentially another
crisis that could bring governments
together
yeah look our institutions increasingly
don't work
and the reason for that is not because
our leaders are bad the reason for that
is because they're old the institutions
are old and they don't they aren't
reformed um yet
and they're meant to be sticky when you
create them because you don't want
people to come in and break them and
make them work for them as opposed to
you because you created it and so it
should work for you but over time you
know the reality is the global economy
changes the balance of power changes but
if the institutions don't change that
means the institutions will start to
fail so i mean an easy example on this
is nafta when we started nafta it
reflected the economy of the us canada
mexico is a great trade agreement and by
the time trump became president it
reflected less than 50 percent of our
trade because data and services not
covered by nafta but increasingly that's
how we trade so the fact that trump blew
it up and created a new nafta was one of
the things that he did that i most
supported
and the reason for that was because we
now have an agreement that reflects the
21st century economic trade between our
countries and it'll last well for
another 20 years or 30 years that's a
good thing and in fact you even there's
a sunset clause so in 10 years you have
to renegotiate it awesome so why is that
relevant well because everything you
just asked me about in terms of global
data and in terms of surveillance
capitalism where companies business
models are driven by making human beings
into products by by profiting off of the
data that they get from us and we in
turn get free services that are no more
free than the dinner oh yeah well the
cost is only our mental health our
democracy our integrity as a society
just just little things like that yeah i
mean you know like when jp morgan you
know takes a billionaire for dinner
that's not a free dinner
right so it's the same it's the same
thing at massive and unprecedented scale
and and with enormous impact on us as
human beings so what do we need and you
and i talked about this when you were
running as president and you and you
even mentioned it on the presidential
debate stage when you were asked about
it which is we need a world data
organization why because we don't have
one i mean it's the most obvious thing
that data drives the 21st century
economy and there is literally no
architecture for it
so how could you not have such an
agreement now a world data organization
would have uh not just governments but
would have
corporations in the space play a much
greater role because unlike in the 20th
century these tech companies function as
sovereigns
in the digital space so it's going to
need to be more of a multi-stakeholder
approach a 21st century solutions
increasingly look like that climate
change solutions increasingly need
corporations and banks in addition to
governments right because in reality is
that's how decisions are made that's how
power is diffused these days but there
is no question given how quickly ai is
advancing given how quickly disruptive
technologies advance and given how much
damage it's doing to our civil society
what the the the behavioral impact that
it has on our kids there's no question
this is urgent and and i will say that
unlike all the other crises
that i have in the book
this is the one that if you ask me ian
is this a goldilocks crisis can we get
this right
i know we can get the other ones right
i'm not sure on this one i think it
might be it might not be it might be
impossible to contain impossible to
regulate and if that's the case then as
a species we're not going to be around
for much longer but if you're not sure
how can you not do everything you can
to at least try to see if it's a
goldilocks crisis and that that's kind
of where we are yeah i used some very
strong language in the book about how
like that this may be the the greatest
threat
and i thought like wow i mean that
that's uh very very very
firm i tend to agree with it let me tell
you why it's i think it's the greatest
threat so it's very specific because
when we had nuclear weapons you know
people thought that that was the
greatest threat but the interesting
thing about nuclear weapons as a
technology it's very complex the
materials are very dangerous and they're
rare so for for 70 years now we have
done a really good job in being able to
contain nuclear proliferation there are
very few organizations in the world that
have nukes or are actively trying to get
them that we don't know about
but when we talk about these disruptive
technologies that are world threatening
like cyber security cyber offensive
cyber weapons or like lethal autonomous
drones right i mean these are weapons
that are going to proliferate maximally
rogue states
criminal organizations will have access
to these weapons within a decade
and so there is a much greater level of
urgency to try to regulate their use to
nudge those that have influence over
them because we know we're not going to
be able to simply stop them and the
advances in artificial intelligence when
we talk about the algorithms that are
literally injected
into our our mental our neural uh
bloodstreams without testing them first
with no idea how they're going to impact
social interactions the only reason we
do it is because we know that that's
what happens to make money for the
companies like that's not sustainable
it's clear that's not sustainable yeah
you had a
passage in the book that really struck
me where you said look if everyone knows
who the strongest is then the incentives
for conflict goes down because you're
like you know you know that let's say in
this case the u.s the most powerful but
if you have a world where you can have
destructive ai and cyber warfare tools
in the hands of rogue actors and the
rest of it then it just becomes a lot
muddier
and the landscape becomes less rational
and clearer and so you wind up
inviting
new forms and sources of conflict oh
yeah i remember when isis after the
second
iraq war and isis rises up and they take
mosul which is the second largest city
in iraq and they grab 800 million
dollars of bank reserves
my immediate worry is oh my god i hope
they don't know anyone that knows how to
code
because with that kind of cash if they
really wanted to disrupt or destroy the
west
they would have a shot and it turned out
they just didn't have that background
they just i mean they they you know they
did some rogue websites that allowed
them to make some money on fake
advertising they did one that you know
mimicked a mercedes-benz site but they
they really didn't have that capacity i
that's not going to be true
in in wars and and massive displacements
um and asymmetric conflicts in the next
decade two decades just won't be true
reading it i was like yeah this is this
is happening and it's going to be very
very difficult because you can imagine a
world where it's just so much harder to
uh somehow safeguard or secure
a site or a system or infrastructure or
network that than it is to uh try and
attack it in my mind it's like and it's
one of the struggles we have these
institutions now is that you have a
political figure who has to come and say
like hey we're ready for x and then
you're like in reality it's like come on
like we know that we know that if
someone really was determined like you
know there there are all sorts of
vulnerabilities yeah yeah i mean it's
funny when i was writing that chapter i
actually i thought to myself that you
were one of the people that
not only was most aligned with the
message but also really would get it
immediately and there there are you know
now i've it's coming out on tuesday and
there are a lot of people in government
that have already read the the draft and
nice work and and
usually when they talk to me they're
like okay well walk me through this
chapter because i don't really get some
of what you're talking about on ai why
is that a bigger threat than climate
change like
it's that's part of the problem is that
the government leaders just don't
understand how fast this has become
existential for our planet
i feel like the eu is the furthest along
in terms of of its
data protection its regulatory approach
many people think that they're
quite adversarial with big tech they're
looking at having a tax regime that uh
like it includes data um i i happen to
think that they you know i mean there
are a couple things i tweak but they
have like like the best approach i've
seen
um out of uh a government um my hope is
that the u.s follows
the eu's lead uh and adopts what
california did around its own gdpr yeah
yeah and to me like the argument was
like i helped out with that california
referendum um that they got higher data
protections uh for californians and then
the argument is you go to other states
and be like why the heck do californians
have these rights and protections that
you don't uh you know the hope is that
maybe you can get state governments to
get their acts together faster than
congress ideally eventually congress
would follow suit and then if you had
the u.s and the eu
approaching this
in a similar way then maybe you could
have the seeds of the world data
organization because those would be the
two biggest actors so that's what i see
is the path
um i don't know
uh you know when when you say like
you're not sure that this one's the
goldilocks scenario like that that would
be my shot at it is start at the state
level and then try and uh get get it
across congress so i i would tweak it a
little um i would say it's to start it's
the eu it's canada and it's japan
because those are the countries that are
most aligned um on the regulatory side
but also don't have the big companies
internally so it's a lot easier for them
as a consequence oh yeah it makes sense
right why is the eu so effective because
they don't have you know the lobbying
and the capturing from local european
companies that are so powerful and and i
think but together with that process
you need to find some of the private
sector actors that are most aligned and
that just in the same way that larry
fink from blackrock
it's not like he cared about the
environment more than other financial
actors but he was the one that first
understood that the world was going to
move in that direction and he thought if
i make that big bet early i will have a
huge advantage over my competition so if
you can convince a couple of the tech
players that no the world is going to
move in this direction you're gonna need
to treat data very differently and if
you're first
you'll actually have the ability to play
a much bigger role right and and and
you'll be able to build the products
that will be much more effective in this
new global order and so take a bet on it
and yeah you're going to have to do the
equivalent of giving up the thermal coal
early but it makes sense for you i think
you want to find and get a few of those
companies involved early and those
companies exist
those companies exist and i think if you
do that
then you have a really good shot of
getting the americans on board now
here's one problem
is
what do you do with the chinese because
there is a credible argument here
that the reason why you can't regulate
the american companies too hard is
because the chinese are at parity with
the united states in a lot of these
disruptive technologies and if you do
anything that weakens the american
companies the chinese will simply end up
with the dominant model
and so if you can't find a way to engage
the chinese on disruptive technologies
um then this whole thing
uh may be a fool's errand and so there i
think you have to as you're building the
world data organization you have to find
at least individual chapters of wdo
accession that the chinese are willing
to engage in and you're willing to give
them a shot of engaging in because we
all understand that otherwise we're
heading to war we're heading the
conflict like quantum computing can't be
just brought in-house right now right
now everyone that's involved in quantum
computing is doing it in-house there's
no sharing in the public sector that
where they are where there is in other
parts of a.i and so when you talk to the
people that are leaders in quantum they
don't know where their competitors are
and and the danger is that you know in
the next 10 years if someone builds an
advanced quantum computer um that that
could make all cryptography
yeah and if the chinese suddenly unveil
that or the americans do then suddenly
the other country i mean is hugely on
the back foot and would have would have
reasons to engage in preemptive strikes
because you just don't catch up at that
point you get to be the superpower the
ai superpower like forever um and create
all the rules and and we should want to
avoid
that kind of sudden insecurity on the
part of powerful countries so i this is
this is a really challenging one but but
i think that the way you're thinking
about it is exactly right um and i'd
like to believe that uh that more people
focusing on this issue will get us to
better solutions which is why i wrote
about it
yeah i i know you and i uh it seems like
we've both been influenced by and in
touch with kaifu lee who writes about uh
oh yeah this competition uh so china has
a couple of structural advantages in
that they have more access to more data
and the government has a tighter
relationship with the
uh their big tech concerns uh i'm told
the chinese government actually invests
directly in compute infrastructure where
they're just islands of servers it
sounds very dystopian like very matrixy
but it's working for them oh yeah i mean
it's smart it's like you know like like
they see
ai as
a crucial arena of competition uh both
militarily and economically
um and like you said in the us
uh our efforts are almost entirely
company-led and you want to avoid this
sense of like an ai arms race but that
that is what it feels like yeah the the
problem is directionally right now we're
heading more
into a cold war with the chinese on ai
and in part that's because of the way we
define national security a little more
broadly than perhaps we should on some
of these issues so you know the fact
that we thought that well even tick tock
potentially was something we need to get
out of the united states because it
means the chinese have access to our
data i mean that it's just different
than huawei and we should treat it as
such but and be clear with the chinese
but secondly because the chinese
themselves for different reasons you
know kept out the facebooks and the
googles from their country
and so some very powerful players in the
united states
don't see any utility and
interdependence with china because they
don't have it and so they're willing to
drive in a much more strategically
competitive direction than the american
chamber of commerce would on issues of
manufacturing and services and the like
so those two things make it harder
to have a global response and if your
response is we're going to regulate ai
really well
in half of the world's economy that's
not going to fix your problem yeah
that's true because every one of the
crises that i'm talking about in this
book don't work unless you have global
agreements i mean you can't like the
pandemic you you manage the pandemic
really well in china for the first year
but the united states and europe says
well
who cares uh then it's coming back with
much more transmissible variance and
frankly like if i were the chinese
government looking at that that would
aggravate me
well you know i was just imagining a
scenario where you actually did get the
us and china to the table and they
agreed on certain guidelines for ai the
fact is i think both sides wouldn't
believe the other side's actually going
to follow through and that's right
so it that that would be a very very
difficult one and when you describe a
scenario where someone announces hey
guys guess what we cracked it like
quantum computing we could like you know
collapse your financial system tomorrow
if we felt like it and then the other
side looks at it and it's like ah i
guess we should we should do something
to that capability
yeah yeah i mean that that's that's the
the knee-jerk response yeah so you want
to worry early before this becomes
something that feels imminent and
therefore feels powerful and enticing to
these governments and this is the right
time to be addressing that issue and i
am convinced that there are areas of ai
and there are areas of disruptive
technologies where you can get
cooperation even between the united
states and china but certainly between
the americans europeans japanese and
that matters a lot so glad that you're
raising
both the alarm and hope uh on what i
agree with you are the most important
issues of our time i'm not sure if we
would have had pandemic on the list uh
pre covid though uh you did very
correctly know it's like look people
have been talking about a pandemic for
years and years uh but before this one
hit that we're going to have others
climate change i think everyone uh gets
disruptive technology not everyone gets
but more and more people
uh are are waking up to it
really grateful that you're actually you
know championing uh international
collaboration which were things that i
when i was running for president i said
look the biggest problems facing us we
can't tackle alone
yeah we can't it's true and you know
again i just i kind of feel like if i
look over the next few months and people
talking about this book and i'm looking
at who else is out there that is
actually looking at these crises through
a lens of they give us the opportunity
to actually change some of the things
that are really worrying us that's not
what i'm seeing i'm seeing a whole bunch
of dystopian the sky is falling
everything's going to hell and by the
way not my problem it's because of them
it's because of those bad people it's
not the democrats the republicans false
not the republicans the democrats faults
not the americans the chinese faults on
the chinese americans fall like that
there is enough of that if that is the
message you want you can go anywhere for
that anywhere to get that it's like
what we're gonna do about it i think
that you know you come here you talk to
me you talk to andrew i i think that
you'll at least be a little bit less
insane um and that's and that's a
helpful thing
oh yeah i i actually have uh some real
hope and optimism about a reorientation
or realignment of american politics
faster than most people think
uh possible there is a lot of negativity
right now i agree
but i'm seeing seedlings
of optimism and hope and action
orientation
things can change faster than most
people think possible unfortunately when
you say that like that that's both bad
as well as good you know yeah
like some you know some of the changes
are gonna be like whoa that got away
from us pretty quick but i also think
some uh rapid positive change is also
uh possible in a way that might not have
been true not that long ago but your
approach also which i really appreciate
is is hopefulness and optimism coupled
with a willingness to fail fast
like you are not someone that continues
to try to beat down a wall if it's not
working you're like okay that doesn't
work i'm going to try this instead
and that we need to do that this is
going to be responding the crises
effectively is also a period of profound
experimentation and rigorous analytic
intent that when something isn't working
you say okay that's fine
we still have this problem let's move to
plan b
yeah amen i mean one of the things i'm
trying to alert people to is that at
this point stances on uh different
topics and issues
at this point
are serving as tribal markers more than
anything else uh because the fact is
like our political system is not going
to deliver on you know 80 90 of the
things that that that any of us would
want and so we have to try and
fix that and then we can go back to
you know hashing out whatever
disagreements
who you might have uh so it's
interesting i mean it's like it's your
it's the case i'm making because i you
know i'm i'm sure it's true um it's not
the case that americans are accustomed
to hearing uh because
where we're so accustomed to being
tribalized and pitted against each other
and said like hey they're the bad guys
you know it's like at this point the
system's the bad guy and if we can get
past that realign the the system so it
responds to you know most of us or more
of us at least
then we'll have a shot at it and then
we'll get together with some of these
other governments and say hey you look
guys the u.s is functioning again
[Laughter]
to go back to where we started i i will
say that um democrats and republicans
right now do agree for however
fleetingly that putin is a worse guy uh
than their enemies across the aisle yeah
and and you have highlighted some of the
the new cohesion and energy around nato
and and democracy now as a response to
that so hopefully the world will rise to
the challenge will rise to the occasion
and if it does i think you'll be a big
reason
why uh you laid out some incredibly
ambitious optimistic uh yet practical
suggestions for
global responses to our biggest problems
and you know we all owe you a debt of
gratitude ian and i owe you a debt for
always giving me a better sense as to
both what's happening in the world and
what we can do better so this book the
power of crisis how three threats in our
response will change the world uh is on
sale
right now i mean this podcast is
probably gonna come out on monday and so
if you order it the book will show up on
your doorstep tomorrow that's right
excellent thanks man i see you real soon
i'm looking forward
[Music]
you